i feel the need to set the table uh you
know sometimes as a host i can i it's my
job to table set it was just at this
very uh i believe moment this actual
moment one week ago fresh off of the
steelers making the playoffs after that
long sunday improbable play-off run to
make that sunday even possible uh die
hard steeler fan joe manganiello was on
the program uh in advance of taking on
the kansas city chiefs um and i i spoke
to him about this uh this match-up uh
and sometimes i like to you know stir
the pot a little bit you but i i i yeah
i i didn't i didn't expect the response
to be very honest with you it was too
good to be true go for it roll it please
i'm assuming you and stone street are
tight through your wife right so
how is that working for for next sunday
night for steelers chiefs how are we
working this one i don't know you know i
mean we i really don't talk football
with him you know
it's it's one of those things where like
you know it's kind of like nouveau riche
versus old money you know wow
we wear it a little differently you know
what i mean to somebody who just comes
out of nowhere and starts winning so
there's a bit of a difference in how we
carry ourselves
[Music]
like a rolex versus richard mealy kind
of oh my
nothing wrong with the reshard meal i'll
say that it's not oh
but i'm just saying you know that would
be more like a diamond-encrusted
breitling or something you know wow that
is a better answer than i could have
ever imagined and that elicited a
response a statement actually a
statement released by eric stonestreet
through his attorney mitchell pritchett
um and um
of course that all set the stage for the
actual football being played um and the
kansas city chiefs despite falling down
seven nothing uh with a defensive
touchdown put on the board by the
i believe future defensive player of the
year tj walker it all went uh kansas
city's way after that joining us here on
the rich eisen show after all that is
the two-time emmy award winner and
friend of the program eric stonestreet
did i set the table properly eric for
this well yeah uh you did rich and uh
hello everyone i hope everybody's doing
well what's up
um
you you know you neglected to
to to say what my statement in response
was which was
you know the kansas city chiefs are a
future
uh looking program we have our eyes
firmly set on the task at hand on sunday
and the future of the organization which
is why we'll have no further comment on
the game last night it's in the past and
we won and now we're moving on to the
buffalo bills well actually uh we do
have the statement on the screen now uh
you did say uh well your attorney said
uh mr stonestreet is looking forward to
the upcoming biopic big ben starring 75
year old actor ed o'neill in the title
role
yeah
yeah yeah i mean i had to i had to you
know look i had to get a couple little
things in there and uh
you quoted you also quoted thomas
jefferson and the great gianni versace i
mean it was really it was virtuoso the
whole thing soup to nuts i put the i we
we put the giant we put the gianni
versace in for
for joe and his italian lineage
oh my gosh so i'm i'm wondering um
you know who gets more delight since
you're a die-hard lover of the chiefs
but even particular offensive line play
to see the thick six as it's now being
known in the nfl when a big man scores a
touchdown if that
uh delighted you the most out of the
sunday night
well it was it was phenomenal when he
checked in lindsay was sitting next to
me i have it on video i said
uh babe don't watch anyone but number 73
right here okay keep your eyes on 73.
and uh
you know here's did you get the pictures
i sent you earlier did indeed we have
them all ready figured you might want to
go in that direction go for it yeah
so
1994 joe valerio scores a tackle
eligible touchdown from joe montana
against the san francisco 49ers
a 19 year old eric is in the second row
uh
season tickets that my dad bought me and
there you'll see the picture on the
screen of joe valerio scoring that
touchdown and right behind joe valerio
if you zoom in in the green polo i have
no idea why i was wearing that and a
black cheese hat
there i am cheering on the tackle
eligible touchdown last night
nick alegretti checked into the game i
tell lindsey do not take your eyes off
73.
he even fooled me when he threw down
what you say is the future defensive
player of the nfl
shook him like a sack of potatoes
went in the end zone caught the
touchdown unbelievable lindsay looked at
me like i was the prognosticator of all
prognosticators she's like you totally
just call back and i'm like yeah
100
so it was quite a full circle moment for
me last night to have
uh the same view same corner of the end
zone that joe valerio scored his one of
his four touchdowns
in kansas city nick allegretti picked it
up last night unbelievable moment
uh it was great look we had
a tight end catch a touchdown
a wide receiver catch a touchdown a
running back catch touchdown pass an
offensive lineman catch a touchdown pass
and we had a tight end throw a touchdown
pass i'd say it was a pretty good
offensive night soup to nuts man i'll
tell you what uh eric the guy who i
would be excited about the most is
jerick mckinnon it looks like they've
got themselves
somebody that is another
weapon that provides a match-up problem
for a defense that already has enough of
that to deal with on their plate with
everybody else coming at them with my
homes you know it's fresh legs and
jericho's always been a good player when
when he's healthy and he's got right
he's got fresh legs right now i mean i'm
just i'm gonna go ahead and you know how
i'm a homer but i'm just gonna go ahead
and chalk this one up to brett beach
again because you know
everything's calculated right and coach
reed and him they know what they're
doing and uh i met jared during training
camp when i was up there doing randy
reed he was the guy i was working with
on the ladder drill hot coals got away
with hot coals got a whiz
great guy awesome dude
and like you i'm like well when's jarek
gonna get the ball it's like well now we
know when jerk's gonna get the ball when
and he just steps in and he reminded me
of jamal charles out there
hmm that's a huge
heaping spoonful of praise right there
i mean hit the hole and then moved i
mean he was he was he looked a little
like jamal in my opinion
and uh you got a kansas state guy to
root for now too i mean you must be out
of your mind with pringle and everything
else going like this so let me tell you
about buying pringle let me tell you
about brian pringle go for it byron
pringle is a pros pro i mean the guy
does
from
what i understand everything
they asked him to do
and he just stands on the sidelines
screaming i would i would i would die to
do this like i would die to do this like
he loves the game of football he is an
exceptional young man like he is the
most infectious personality the greatest
smile of course he went to kansas state
has the cutest little kids he's a great
follower on instagram his kids are so
adorable i am so happy for byron pringle
because he isn't you know
he is an example of work ethic
being a likable partner in a
relationship you know doing what you're
asked to do and then he's getting better
man they're giving him more
opportunities and that sluggo route that
he ran last night was
perfection eric stonestreet here on the
rich eisen show okay so your level of
concern moving forward is what we got
for me well listen
here's the deal man
buffalo is a great team
they're a great team the best the best
game
before the super bowls next sunday night
at arrowhead the best matchup the two
best teams are meeting next sunday at 5
30 at arrowhead i will be there
and you know what i can't take anything
away from buffalo i love josh allen
i love him
he is exactly the type of football
player i'd want my quarterback to be
you know what i mean
if it's not my home if i didn't already
have my homes you know what i'm saying
like right i mean
i'm in the same position he's he's my
choice if if we don't have patrick
mohammed so you know look as a fan
my worry has to do more with being a
chiefs fan my whole life i go i was
worried going into last night's game i
mean because i'm not in control of
anything i don't have the knowledge of
knowing the match-ups like coach reid
and everybody else knows so i'm always
worried but look buffalo's tough match i
mean
new england did not play well i know
brockman would like me saying that they
did not play well they sucked i don't
think i don't think the score was a true
reflection
but i mean buffalo's incredible i mean i
i if we play like we played last night
they play like they played last night
the advantage goes to us i think
slightly just because of home field
what's the spread like in your suite
what's it like oh what do you got there
i do just like uh we just do like normal
stadium food i'm not a fancy football
guy so we always have chili we always
have nachos got it we always have some
kind of a hot dog brat kraut
a chicken wing usually
no sweets a lot of soda a lot of pop
okay so you don't you don't bring any of
your own uh you don't bring your own
what brisket risk you don't bring any of
those
come on they have they don't let you do
that that's what that's that's one of
the things funny things about arrowhead
is like
they they they're proud of the food they
serve in those sweets let me tell you
that okay yeah but you could sneak in a
pork butt and a backpack you know what i
mean you know what i i'll tell you this
i did sneak in my own jalapenos this
year no all right so that's well that's
a gateway that's a gateway that's a
gateway food to the bigger stuff you
care i mean no right yeah in fact
i love these olives brand i sliced
jalapeno so i i packed some in my in my
coat one game i i made somebody else
walk in with them though in case i got
caught i was like
a fall guy
you had a food fall guy at arrowhead
yeah it's not your first rodeo it's not
eric stonestreet's first rodeo okay so
it was a great it was a great night we i
mean i was i was i was nervous but uh
i was
i mean i was just like wow i guess we
decided we wanted to score touchdowns
i mean i look i that and that's the
thing i'm i'm loving about
the finale of divisional playoff weekend
right is that
that that that the chiefs did what they
did i mean they busted they took that
playbook and busted it wide open after a
first quarter where the steelers defense
was definitely effective to say the
least okay and they they got what they
needed which was a defensive score
to to start things off
um
and then they busted that playbook open
and then busted the steelers over the
head with it and
and and took care of business and the
bills just had the first ever
uh every possession being a touchdown no
possession ending in anything but a
touchdown in the history of the nfl
um
it's it's lit it's the stage is set i'm
very excited yeah i mean
it's it's the
the best matchup is next sunday night at
arrowhead i think cincinnati has a good
chance of beating
tennessee and tennessee
[Music]
and i think cincinnati comes to
arrowhead for the afc championship if
we're fortunate enough to get past
buffalo
cincinnati certainly does not do what
they did to us before again now i'm
mandated to ask you what happens on the
nfc side what do you think happens there
yep what do you think happens well
i i would like
kansas city green bay uh super bowl for
nostalgia purposes yes in los angeles
but you know me i would also like my
shot at mr brady again
[Laughter]
[Music]
be careful what you wish for
be careful
i
i hate how much i love that guy
i do
be careful eric and so uh again knowing
how die hard a fan you are and that you
know that things need to be one at a
time and you need to take care of
business and you don't want to upset
football gods have you already reached
out
to the goods rg
for uh a spot uh should the chiefs make
the super bowl or does he already know
that there's
you're stone street plus one at least
for that thing does he already know that
but is that done he he unfortunately
made a deal with the devil when he
invited me to the super bowl years ago
yes and i said i would not go until the
chiefs are in it and i meant every time
the chiefs
you sure did you read the fine print did
you you need to read the fine print
you know he knows that i will come a
call in but listen here's the deal
he's
i learned pretty early on that afc
championship game where i thought we
were going to super bowl and tom brady
took care of that yes uh i was with with
roger and i was getting pretty pretty
emotional and excited and he was the one
that was like you need to you need to
win the game
don't go there yet like he was
so crazy he was measured he
kept me down so i don't contact him
until uh
you know until it's time he's seen a few
games
he's seen a few games uh all right last
one for you since we brought him up
before and i adore him how is that
o'neil doing
oh my gosh he's great what do you got
for me he's great what do you got for me
anything um anything good
he uh texted me the other night eric
because i got him hooked on these
steaks from kansas city
great
little plug here veteran-owned business
called kansas kansas city cattle company
very good veteran owned ventured
operated great steaks the best i'll send
you some rich okay but i got add on to
him i gave him to him for christmas last
year
and
this is so classic at o'neill so i sent
him a box of steak right
two weeks later the guys from kansas
city cattle company called me and they
were like uh we just got off a 45-minute
conversation with ed o'neill
and this is a small little cattle
company in like western missouri and i
was like what and they said yeah he just
called the number on the on the receipt
of the steak and
one to talk to us and we had a 45-minute
conversation with them about meat and tv
and football and everything else what a
great time like that's ed o'neill
that's him anyway so this week before
the game he's like eric i'm thinking
about cooking something up for the
steelers game
how would you recommend i do one of
these casey cattle company sirloins
and i said well so i sent him an audio
text back you know how you press and
hold of how i would do it yes and then
he just simply wrote beautiful butterfly
that's what i'll do i'll butterfly it so
then i start getting pictures of the
preparation of the butterfly of a
furloin and then i guess right as he's
ready to cook it he texts me and he goes
eric
that audio message you sent me has
disappeared from my phone i can't find
it anywhere where you tell me what to do
with the garlic and the oil yeah you
gotta hit keep you didn't hit keep well
i had anticipated this i did keep it
i kept it and saved it and then just
sent it back to him and he goes how did
you do that how did you just see that
oh he's he he's literally
literally the greatest of all time he is
man he is
i would love to see he was watching the
game last night eating a sirloin steak
and then he was gonna make a sandwich
out of the leftovers and
he's excited to come to kansas city
sometime i wish i could get him here i
mean i wish i could get him here to a
game he loves patrick mahomes he's just
no who doesn't
and i just love that he roots for the
steelers even though you know uh
chuck noll cut him in 1969 but i guess
it started his stupendous career so
there's no hard feelings you know i love
that unbelievable uh but i'm i'm excited
man i uh
okay you know rich like if you would if
19 year old me in that picture
that you put up or hopefully put up for
people
knew that the game of all games would be
at arrowhead
and that i would be there
and we would be playing for you know and
potentially another super bowl
like my football dreams are coming true
thanks to coach reed patrick mahomes
pratt beach and the kansas city chiefs
like this is all a die hard fan ever
wants is a chance to be the team that
people talk about
and that's
that's where we are i'm so happy
i guess i love everything about my
football life and then right now what
the 50 year old eric stone street would
be asking the 19 year old why you were
in the green shirt to arrowhead i i can
only think it was just pure
fashion it was the only clean thing
maybe because i remember when i was 19
years whatever was clean i think it was
like i think it was me being like the
lady death protest too much
i need to just rock a green polo
khaki pants brown woven belt maybe some
desert boots and then i'll just throw it
in a hint of my fandom on my lap
but now as you know
lindsey embarrassingly has to admit
chief stuff is basically all i wear
i know you sent me that text of you just
winking at the uh at your camera last
night and i showed that to to my wife i
showed it to susie she goes you wore
that to the game i'm like i think that's
what he wears all the time you know
that's all i i mean i look like the
coaching staff
you're randy reed thanks for the time
eric you're the best brother you take
care of yourself we'll just chat soon
there you go that'll be a tough game
we're looking forward to the matchup all
right there you go that's eric stone
street the nouveau riche eric stone
street
when the money gets spent no matter what
right there jalapeno fall guy
jalapeno fall guy write that down it's a
great fantasy team name
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here